hey guys it's max we just got the new
galaxy s 20 ultra and we're very excited
to test it out and not only get our
first hands-on impressions but also
compare it to dive own 11pro max which
i've been using since lunch and this is
going to be your typical comparison
where we just talk about specs and read
off of the website we're gonna look at
some detailed things such as the display
brightness and quality speakers even LTE
speeds with the 5g here compare it to
Apple's best offering so let's go ahead
and jump right into it I'm gonna open up
the box here and grab that first glance
I know this phone is massive and Wow
okay so first impressions this camera
bump is huge not only you know visually
but my finger just rest naturally right
up here and it literally is like pushing
against the little edge there let me set
aside by side with the iPhone so Apple
actually made theirs smaller this year
the camera bump it doesn't stick out as
much and Samsung they just went all the
way now I get away Samsung is calling
this the ultra this thing is massive the
camera bump is massive and if you're
somebody that doesn't like your phone to
rock well Samsung doesn't care about
this at all anymore so if putting on the
site by site surprisingly that's 20
Ultra feels very similar in weight to
the iPhone 11 pro max we'll put the
weights right up there for you guys
obviously it is larger as you guys can
see its taller but as far as the width
here not only is a Samsung's body
thicker but then when you add in the
camera bump it's a pretty big difference
now just like the note 10 we don't have
any buttons or switches here on the left
hand side whereas the iPhone you have
your volume rocker and then you have
your physical silent switch which I
really really like and then on the other
side here the iPhone just has this power
button where here we have the volume
rocker and then we also have the power
button and I like this configuration
where I can do everything with my right
hand since I am right-handed the iPhone
has a lightning port whereas the CMC has
USB type-c which I prefer and with
Samsung we only have a speaker grille on
one side but of course on the iPhone
this other side is just for looks and
let's finish off the exteriors with the
backs they're both made out of glass so
that we can have wireless charging the
Samsung is glossy whereas the
is Matt now I like the feeling of the
glassy just because it gives you a nice
grip but the Matt just feels more
pleasant more premium and then of course
we have our camera bumps and it seems
like these phone companies are not
trying to one-up each other instead of
making small bumps and trying to make
everything blend in they're just going
massive so the iPhone made this design
here which looks really nice you
instantly know who has an iPhone 11 I
really like this looks very premium and
the Samsung jumps in with this massive
camera bump it's almost like a Hummer
it's in-your-face compared to a nice
Porsche something like that now I will
be switching over from the iPhone 11 Pro
max which I've used since launch and I
really like overall to the s20 ultra for
at least a week and then making a video
showing you guys every single thing I
noticed all the fine details of what
it's like going over all the good things
and also all the bad things so make sure
you guys are subscribed so you guys
don't miss out in that video nas's phone
is setting up let me talk about the
chargers and batteries both come with
USB C chargers now which is great so the
Samsung is 25 watts compared to 18 watts
with the iPhones and as far as batteries
the iPhone has almost 4,000 milliamp
hours whereas the Samsung has 5000 which
is a massive number but don't expect
that you're gonna get better battery
life especially if you're gonna stay at
that 120 Hertz and now it's time to set
up our security and the Samsung does
have facial recognition as you guys see
but it's just using a standard camera
it's not the ultra secure face unlock
face ID that Apple has so I'm gonna go
instead with the fingerprint recognition
and just like the other phones they
actually have it underneath the display
no don't download Microsoft Office Excel
powerpoints none of that none LinkedIn
no things I knew something's gonna
happen if they're partnering with
Microsoft now they have all this stuff
on here let's see how these compare as
far as unlocking your phone BAM we tap
pull up very quick Apple's optimize this
over time I pretty much don't even
notice it now that I got used to the
iPhone
and then let's see if Samsung is
optimized for their third version of the
sensor so I should be able to just put
it in the right spot there you go that's
surprisingly quick actually and it's
getting it each time now let's get into
comparing the displays and the first
thing when a test is that 120 Hertz
display now I love that on the iPad pro
and I start flicking back and forth here
and it seems like it's very very close
so then I went into the settings and out
of the box it's actually defaulted to
not only 60 Hertz just your standard but
it's also defaulted to 1080p resolution
so right for this time we can actually
choose between 1080 at 120 or you can
get the better quality but I want to
play around with that 120 okay there you
go there it is so you guys are watching
out 24 frames per second let us give you
guys a slow-motion shot right here and
you guys could see side by side we have
a lot more frames with the Samsung
compared to the iPhone so you see that
smoothness difference when we slow it
down not only do we have a higher
refresh rate but the animations are also
quite a bit quicker on the Samsung now
obviously we don't need extra frame
rates to go through your icons faster
but where do you really notice this 120
Hertz is when you're scrolling through
webpages everything looks super sharp
and crisp we're not getting motion blur
and then just doing simple things like
opening up folders and programs
everything just feels so much more
snappier and once you get used to a 120
Hertz screen it's hard to go back to a
60 Hertz nutz compare the full manual
brightnesses of these phones we're gonna
use Google here and as you guys can see
if we max up both these turn off auto
brightness the iPhone is actually quite
a bit brighter and the Samsung if we
close the browser and open it again it
starts out brighter and then dims and
that's actually a sort of a power saving
feature so it doesn't get too bright in
manual mode and if we open up the verge
and we have less white on the screen
it's about even I was still slightly
brighter but it's very similar however
if you're gonna go outside and you have
auto brightness enabled then they are
very close in fact the Samsung might be
just slightly brighter as long as you're
in the auto mode now as far as viewing
angles both of these look very
very similar I see a little bit more
reflections from the Samsungs display
but as far as brightness and contrast I
mean they both look very good and it
makes sense because I'm pretty sure that
Samsung makes the panel that's in the
iPhone and now let's compare the display
quality when we're playing back HDR
videos I have two videos opened up right
here and it's very interesting that as
soon as you play back HDR the color
balance of the Samsung s20 ultra changes
it gets much warmer and it's actually
brighter and it allows that screen to
get that full brightness compared to the
iPhone here now of course we're not
recording an HDR so you guys aren't
watching back in HDR I had to turn that
camera down so we can see the full
brightness without blowing it out and
the first thing that pops out to me
personally is how much brighter the
whites and the highlights are on the
Samsung then we didn't have this big of
a difference with the note 10 I don't
believe so either they tuned the
software or just display is better than
the previous ones
but it looks a little bit richer and in
HDR the highlights are just so bright
you could definitely tell us HDR where's
the iPhone it just looks like maybe
slightly more dynamic range than a
standard display now I know that I phone
doesn't look bad it definitely looks
better than previous ones but the
Samsung is definitely one upping it and
finally with the displays let's talk
about those bezels now the iPhone didn't
look bad when it launched everyday using
is totally fine but when you put a
side-by-side with this Samsung you can
clearly see how much thinner the bezels
are both on the top and bottom and
especially on the sides now the iPhone
screen does slightly curved just a
little bit to make it more comfortable
and I'm really glad that with the s 20s
they actually tone down the curve and
now something I'm excited for comparing
the speakers and I do want to say that I
am gonna go in and enable Dolby Atmos
because it does make it sound better I
have no idea why this is not enabled by
default it just does not make sense to
me but there it is and we're gonna go
ahead and get started with the iPhone
and I'll cut between them you guys let
me know which one sounds better to you
in the comment section below
[Music]
now we are recording with a nice
microphone into a recorder but there's
lots of variables it's compressed on
YouTube it depends on what you're
listening through but I will say that
the Samsung is quite a bit louder
actually tested it out with my Apple
watch and it hit three decibels louder
which is a significant difference now as
far as sound quality in the mids and the
highs I'm very surprised by how close
these are and it's interesting to see
these phones just one-upping each other
after each new phone comes out so
loudness definitely Samsung wins the
clarity it's awesome but there's also a
difference in bass with iPhone 11 Pro
max you actually feel a little bit of
the thump there where it sounds more
like just like a sound of base with the
s20
ultra wow this feels laggy going back
and opening this up not only this little
animations but my eyes got used to this
120 Hertz very quickly so now let's go
ahead and test out the CPU and graphics
performance we do have two snapdragon
variant and that is the 865 going
against the a 13 Bionic let's go ahead
and test out the CPU we have a
multi-core score that is fairly similar
the iPhone is beating it by just a
little bit but what the single core the
iPhone has over 40 percent more
performance in these tests now that is
very surprising
obviously Apple is doing a great job
with their processors but I do have to
note that in the real world we have more
than enough performance with both of
these Ram is one of the limiting things
with the iPhone we have 4 gigs of RAM
and with that I do find that background
apps will actually close on me at times
and it's really frustrating whereas with
the s20 ultra we have 12 gigs of ram on
this particular model now with the
graphics test here the numbers don't
really line up testing between metal and
say OpenCL or Vulcan so we're actually
gonna be doing a separate test we're
gonna be playing some games
seeing how performs in the real world
and we'll give you guys some benchmark
numbers there as well
so make sure you guys are subscribed and
now let's compare the internet speeds
I'm starting off with the iPhone and I
am on t-mobile here and inside we have 3
out of 4 bars of LTE of course I have
one does not have 5g and this is
something I struggle with sometimes a
certain
I have no reception or poor reception
and speeds as well so we'll see how the
5g works now with t-mobile rats we don't
have the millimeter wave but we do have
the sub six it's gonna be very
interesting to see so we got nine point
seven megabit per second for both which
is not very good and that is a pretty
significant difference so we're getting
57 58 59 60 now 5g as you guys can see
five out of five and once again this is
the sub six which is better at
penetrating through walls and buildings
and stuff like that which matters a lot
now on the upload interestingly we're
only getting about half of what we're
getting on the iPhone 5.4 compared to
nine point seven so that is a pretty big
difference if you care about your speeds
if you want to stream 1080 60fps HDR
video download things and what I'm
really interested about is in this next
week that I'm going to be testing out
the s20 ultra switching over in certain
areas where I have no reception I want
to see if that's gonna help a lot and I
will fill you guys in in that video so
now let's finish off just talking about
the prices now this phone comes in at
$1,100 people were shocked when Apple
start charging a thousand bucks for the
iPhone 10 and with the s20 ultra Samsung
is not being shy at all fourteen hundred
dollars for this phone that is crazy
it does have 128 gigs of storage
compared to 64 over here and for 200
bucks more you go to 512 and I'll also
get 16 gigs of ram compared to 150 bucks
more on the iPhone and that gets you to
256 gigs what's the same amount of RAM
so this one is more expensive but it
does have some extra features and
especially the LTE both sub 6 and 5
gigahertz and of course a lot more
cameras now you guys saw that we did not
cover the cameras that's going to be a
way more detailed bigger video there's a
lot to compare here especially with the
new additions so make sure you guys are
subscribed with notifications enable if
you guys wanna see our very detailed
camera comparison this Ben Max and I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]